- [Mark] All right, Bobo.
- Yes, sir?
- [Mark] Bobo, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Bobo] Oh, I'm from Los Angeles.
I'm from Venice Beach.
Venice.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- [Bobo] Venice, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents, growing up?
- Yes, sir.
Well, my dad...
Well I was just telling you a while ago,
he moved and went to Louisiana.
My mom got married, her second marriage,
I think second or third marriage.
And my stepdad...
Okay, as I was a kid growing up,
they was always arguing and fighting.
And then by me being like,
what, five or six years old,
you know how you get scared and nervous
when you see grown people fight, whatnot?
That's the problem that I went through.
As I was going outside and
doing a lot of, you know,
playing, running around
with my friends and stuff,
there's this one Mexican dude, older cat.
And he liked the young boys.
So he used to call me,
"Bo, come here, come here. I
got some money to give you."
And I believed that, by me being young
like I used to be, right?
So I went over there
and see what he wanted.
He took me in the garage.
He said, "Come here."
And I'm looking at him,
like, with his clothes off.
I'm like, something
wrong with this picture.
But I'm not knowing, by me
being five or six years old.
I'm not really knowing
what's really going on.
I'm thinking, you know,
by us living so close to the beach area,
that he's changing his drawers, whatnot,
to put something else on to go swimming.
Then he go out there and
go swimming with his kids
and nephews and cousins,
stuff like that, right?
At that time, there was
the people, his kids,
I used to play with a whole lot.
So he got up on top of
a bench or something,
and his penis was hard and
he had a towel over it.
And he asked me to put my mouth on it.
And I was scared; I was shocked.
I'm not knowing what's going on, you know?
And I'm looking at this like,
"Put my mouth on that?!"
You know, my mind was somewhere else, now.
And I kinda did it, because I was scared,
I ain't know he gonna kill me or not,
'cause the way he was looking in his face.
He had that look, like, "Come on!"
You know what I mean?
So I'm like, what am I supposed to do?
So after I did, I left.
Ran out the garage, crying.
Ran all the way home,
almost got hit by a car.
Crying, "Mama, mama, mama."
My mama, she was looking at me like,
"What's wrong with you, Bo?"
I said, I don't know, I can't
remember the dude's name,
but he was a Mexican guy, I know that.
That's what he was, right?
And I said his name, and
my mama said, "What?"
"He had me put my mouth on his thing."
So my mom's like, "Oh, hell no."
So she called her brother, Terry.
He come over and he asked
me, "What happened, nephew?"
And I told him.
So we all go back across the street.
He wasn't nowhere around to be seen.
He was gone and whatnot.
So time went by,
my stepdad did the same thing.
But I ain't put my mouth on his penis.
He always liked to rub on my butt,
you know, what's the word, molesting?
That's what he was doing to me.
Now, this is a story that it
happened to me from a child,
working my way up to the age of 10, okay?
After that happened, I was so...
My English is kinda messed up.
I was sort of the hystecocal or something?
Stucco-
Costecocal?
Well, okay. Well anyway, I was so scared.
I'm talking about-
- [Mark] Hysterical?
- Hysterical.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- Yeah, so...
I didn't know what to do.
So I got to saying...
I'm the only child in my family.
I got to crying, crying.
I'm not knowing what to...
Every time I go to
school, I get in trouble,
because of how I was feeling.
You see what I'm saying?
So I'm like, wow, this is crazy.
When I was seven...
When I was seven,
I went over this lady house,
and whatever I asked her, you know...
Her name is Betty Cheedums.
I'd go over her house and I asked her,
"Can I do some kind of work?"
You know what I mean?
Like cut grass or
something, wash your car.
Whatever, help you plant.
She always gave me a job.
But a lot of times when I
get up, and she's get up,
and I asked, "Can I use your bathroom?"
I goes, she said, "Yeah."
I go up in the bathroom,
leave the bathroom door open, whatever.
You know what I mean?
And do what I gotta do.
When I come out, it's just seemed like
we sitting on the couch together.
She asked me to sit close to her
when I was like, seven, right?
I guess she was, what, in her thirties
or something, at that time.
And it was just a feeling that...
After that happened, for me in the garage,
put my mouth on the
penis, or after, you know,
things like that happened
to me with my stepdad,
as things that happened
to me with this lady here,
I didn't know what to do.
I didn't know what to say, you know.
By you being young like
that, your mind, you know,
you're not thinking clear.
You're not, you know, on
that path, that same path.
What I'm trying to say is,
the age of seven you're not on that page.
Your mind is somewhere else.
You know what I mean?
Like scared. Scared type,
the thoughts come out,
you know, me thinking scared.
So my moms, she would take me to,
not a nursing home, or
something to give evaluation.
You know, to check my
butt, to check and see
if anything's open, whatnot.
I had, you know, I'm
going through this pain.
This situation by me being the only child.
I didn't know what...
I'm not knowing and understanding anything
at that young age.
You know, so I'm just,
I really too much...
I was ashamed by doing
anything with my friends,
when that happened to me.
I was ashamed.
Because I didn't want to
go play baseball with 'em,
football, you know, things
like that as a sport.
You know what I mean?
When I was growing up.
So now when I got about 12, 13 years old,
I go and spend a night on my cousin house.
And the same thing happened to my cousin,
but she's a female, you know what I mean?
And I seen that, when I opened the door.
He supposed to be the third cousin?
You know how you have
first, second, third cousin?
Yeah, he raped my cousin.
And I'm standing at the door
with tears in my eyes at 12 years old.
Then I run up out of there
and go tell my uncle, Charles.
You know, your brother's in
there, or cousin, whatever,
in there raping Nikki.
That's her name, Nikki.
I been through all that.
Now around the same age as this lady,
she's the manager of the
apartments down in Venice.
And she was out there growing
watermelon seeds, watermelon.
She plants watermelon
seeds on the ground, okay?
I go in there and ask
her, her name was Medea,
I'm like, "Medea, is it possible
"I can help you throw some seeds?"
She said, "Sure, come on
precious, get down here.
"This is what you do, you make the hole,
"dig the hole with the little shovel,
"and put, like, two or
three seeds in the ground."
So I was doing that.
Medea got tired.
She was like 80 some
years old at that time.
And I was like 12.
She got tired, went up in the house.
"I'll be back, I'm gonna
go get some water."
She went up in the house.
I'm steady putting seeds in the ground.
Now ain't no more seeds
on top of the dirt,
'cause they all in the hole.
So I walked and sat up on the stairs.
I'm sitting like the way I'm
sitting now, looking down.
A face came up out the ground,
I don't know if it was
Jesus or the Devil, or what.
Said, "Bobo, would you
like to work for me?"
I'm looking, like, I see a face!
But I don't know who this person is.
And I'm like, "No!" The
face disappeared that fast.
So as it disappeared that
fast, I got up and ran,
almost got hit by a car.
So as I'm runnin' out the gate,
a car was coming and I didn't see the car.
So I almost got hit by a
car when I ran out the gate.
And the car skid and whatnot,
and I kept on running.
And as I kept running,
my mom and you know,
I'm in there crying, you
know, I was, like, scared.
You know, I wasn't a tough
guy when I was a kid.
This scared, you know, the
things had happened to me,
you know, made me feel like
that I was what the bad guys or something,
or why I gotta be me.
Why me?
All these things happened to me, you know?
So, down the line,
I looks at things.
The older I get, I see how my cousin is.
He's a homosexual.
I got, like, three or four
cousins is homosexual.
I got cousins, female, they dykes.
They, like, mess with other women.
And I sit there and watch
and just be lookin' at these
when we have a family unit thing.
All the family come over,
and I see he come down here.
He come up in here with his boyfriend.
"Oh, this is my boyfriend" so so so so.
And I'm looking at him like, wow.
I mean, the things that happened to me,
should I be like that?
I mean, you know, by him
being my cousin, was he,
did he get raped when he was a child,
so all of a sudden he like that, now?
It's all...
The things that went down
with me when I was a child,
I don't too much speak about it,
because I don't like to, you know...
Do a man supposed to cry
when he knows that this happened to him?
And then you older now.
And then you, all of a
sudden, you feel, you know,
by talking about it, you
know what I'm saying,
you know, cry.
I feel like I got tears
in my eyes right now.
Like I want to just drip 'em.
You know what I mean?
But I don't know how, I don't know how.
Because I guess the
person I used to carry,
you know what I mean.
- [Mark] How did all this stuff,
all the sexual abuse as a
child, affect you as an adult?
- Right now? Okay.
Tell you the truth, being honest with you,
I hate it.
I hate it real tough.
I don't like to sit next to a man.
I don't know, I don't care where I'm at.
If a man sits here, I get angry.
I want him to sit somewhere else, okay?
If you asked me, get on
a motorcycle with you,
I won't do it.
That's how it affects me.
I get angry, real mad, if I'm
sitting next to another man.
Right now, today, I'm 55 years old.
Let me sit next to a man, I'm getting up.
I don't want to sit next to him.
Now, not only that, I
got so bothered that,
after all that happened to
me, you know what I mean?
I got like, what are you call them?
Gay guys and stuff as
my friend now, you know?
But like I said, I'm 55.
I got gay guys as my friend now, you know.
And I go to their house or something
and sit down and be looking
and be thinking like,
wow, when I was a kid, when I was younger,
I didn't want to be sitting
next to another man.
Now I hear myself in the
house was with gay guys.
You know what I mean?
Doing things that gay guys do, you know.
Like, say for instance,
dancing with him, you know what I mean?
I have done that.
I'm like, "Man, what the, what I'm doing?
"No, no, no, no, I can't do that."
You know what I mean, I'm tripping.
"On man, I got to go."
This ain't my party.
This ain't my piece of cake.
I don't belongs here,
you know what I mean?
I caught myself doing that.
And it's a trip, man.
It's a trip how things, you know,
you can't blame it on the world.
Blame yourself.
That's how I see, that's how I look at it.
Because when I was young like that,
what'd I do to be treated that way?
What'd I do to be treated
that way when I was young?
When I'm a little older now it's like...
Nah, kind of skeptical to go
in the house with that man.
Nah, I can't do that.
But now when I see, oh, I seen my cousin,
his name is Donny Manny,
you know, having sex with another man.
I seen that happen.
You know, he called me over
to deliver some things.
And that's what I did.
I went over there, knocked at the door,
knocked at the door, knock at the door.
Didn't want to answer.
Go to the window, tapped on the window.
The curtain is open.
There they is, having sex in the bed.
That threw me off.
It threw me off, like if I
fell off the rollercoaster
or something, you know what I mean?
It's like, my family is messed
up in the heads or something?
You know what I mean?
Was I the bad guy for me
to have this happen to me?
Or what's going on with this family?
Why all the men's is acting funny?
You know, stuff like that.
But you know, we got to live one day.
You got to live and stay strong, you know?
And you know, you were
born to be a man, you know.
And stay in man place.
Got a little circle around,
stay in your circle.
Be a man and keep walking forward.
You know what I mean?
Trust in God.
You know, because I see
myself going to church a lot.
You know what I mean?
We all have bad things.
We all have good things.
But who you going to serve?
You gonna serve the Lord, or Satan?
Joshua 24:15 said, "now
if seem evil unto you
"to serve the Lord, choose you
this day, who you will serve.
"Whether it's my father served
what's on the other side
"of the flood, or my
father and the Amorites,
"in whose land you dwell.
"But as for me and my house,
we will serve the Lord."
And I want to say this one more verse.
And I hope everybody gets this verse
and hope you take heed of it.
Says John 14th chapter, one to five.
"Let not your heart be in trouble:
"believe in God, believe also in me.
"In my father's house of many mansions,
"if it wasn't so, I
wouldn't have told you.
"I go prepare a place for you.
"Wherever I go to prepare a place for you,
"I'll come again to
receive you unto myself;
"wherever I'm at, there ye be also."
I thank God for all of
you, everybody in the world
who is looking at this on the YouTube.
I just ask you right now,
keep your head up and stay focused on God.
Amen.
- [Mark] How did this affect
your relationships with women?
- Okay, no, I do have a wife.
- [Mark] Oh you do?
- So you want me... ?
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah, just...
- Okay, not a problem.
Hmm, okay, hmm.
Well, to be honest with you,
I, myself, you know,
I'm in to, I'm trying to,
I want to bring the word
out my mouth the right way.
Not, you know, the words
we use on the streets.
(makes rapid sounds)
(chuckles)
So, you know, I love
making love to my wife.
It don't really too much affect me.
It make me just want to
be that man to my wife
to make love to her everyday.
But she's not the type of
person that do it every day.
But now, oh, here's another
thing, since we brung that up.
Back with y'all again.
You know, when kids,
little kids around you,
like little girls and stuff.
And they see you and you know, "Oh Bobo!"
They want to run a jump
on your lap, little girls?
Oh, I can't do that.
That's how, that's how it affects me.
I see a lot of guys, they
pick up, they do all that.
They let him sit on their lap
and you know, stuff like that.
I seen that, but I can't do that.
I can't do that with none of my,
none of the girls in my family.
You know, is a baby laying
there is a girl is crying,
and somebody asks me, "Oh, go on, then.
"Pick up my daughter."
I'm not going to pick up that daughter.
I'm going to look around and call you.
"Hey man, come on in here
and get this little girl."
- [Mark] Is it because
you're attracted to her?
- No.
- [Mark] Or just, you're
just not comfortable?
- I'm not comfortable
with what happened to me,
when I was young.
- [Mark] Yeah. You don't
want anything similar to it?
- No.
- No. I don't want...
Because I hears a lot of things,
he's a great listener, he's you
know, child stuff, you know.
I be in, nah, nah, nah.
I'm good on that.
You know what I mean?
Because in fact what happened to me...
- [Mark] You've never had
any kind of experiences
as an adult, that are... ?
- No, no, no, no, no, no,
not too much, because...
(chuckles)
- [Mark] Not too much or not at all?
- No.
- Well, I'm going to say not too much,
because a lot of times, okay.
At the time though, I was
just, I didn't really too much.
I can't, I just can't.
When the kids come to me, I'm like,
"Oh, stop. Pump the brakes, man.
"You know, you walking up too close."
I don't care if you my niece, my nephew,
you're walking up to close.
But I won't say that to them though.
I was like, "All right, what you want?"
Wait, wait, whoa.
This hand goes here, this hand go here.
Come on, let's clap, clap.
I play along with him.
- [Mark] So you're afraid
that something might happen?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] With you?
- Yes.
- [Mark] So you're very careful.
- I'm very careful.
- [Mark] To make sure it doesn't.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] And it never did?
- It never did.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Never did.
- In my lifetime. Never.
Because I'm not going out backwards.
- [Mark] I wish more people
could do what you did.
- Amen, brother.
I'm not going out backwards,
you know what I mean?
'Cause...
- [Mark] It wasn't your fault,
what happened to you as a kid.
- No, no, it wasn't my fault.
But look, boy, I like to knock the crazy.
I like to see him being, but
you know, but I don't know.
God is good, man. All the time.
- [Mark] All right, Bobo.
- [Bobo] Amen, brother.
- [Mark] Thank you very much, man.
- [Mark] Yes, sir.